this looks like a big baguette but it's
not it's a giant log of cookie
[Music]
hey what's up my name is Tui and welcome
to making it big the show where we take
your favorite foods and turn it giant
colossal gargantuan I have a very
special guest today and it just happens
to be her birthday so I really have to
do a great job at whatever she
challenges me to do so let's give it up
for the birthday girl
welcome what do I see in your hands only
one of my favorite childhood snacks
pot actually liked the opposite
like pretty small they're so small yeah
how big do we want this
humongous like a lightsaber flavor wise
what flavors are we working with
chocolate matcha strawberry and cookies
and it's really good I got good taste do
you want me to pick one all of them oh
your toy so you can do it I am very
excited this will be the best birthday
gift ever and I really appreciate you
good luck thanks good luck
let's do this
the fact that I have this mountain of
butter and this a mountain of flour and
it all has to be used is a little bit
daunting I have to nail this shortbread
cookie dough so two pounds of flour it's
gonna go right into my food processor
about a cup of sugar a tablespoon of
baking powder one and a half teaspoons
of kosher salt worried for this machine
because it might overheat but
keep a close eye on it
okay and then one pound of butter right
into here okay I'm gonna give this a
pulse
most of the equipments here that we have
aren't really equipped to make big food
I'm trying my best to not break it
so this mixture has gotten a little bit
flakier so I'm gonna add my vanilla into
the milk
this together and drizzle it in
[Applause]
okay well it just decided to stop on its
own sorry
didn't mean to bother but this
look by the way this is only one batch
for one dough and it's only vanilla we
actually have to make a chocolate dough
as well I have a lot of work to do but
we're off to a really good start I want
to shape my dough and it's gonna be
great I hope Jasmine is hungry because
this is only one Pocky oh man
the blade chopped off
a little bit of my spatula you know
extra flavor so I'm using a sieve to
dust my flour so there are no lumps I
can't believe that this is actually just
one Pocky this
it's already so massive shortbread
cookies are very tricky to begin with
and they're very delicate so I know that
this is a very sensitive boy right here
it's wanting to fall apart I'm gonna let
this sit in the fridge so I can firm up
that way it'll be easier for me to roll
it out one vanilla batch down I'm going
to put this in the fridge for an hour
while I wait for that I'm gonna make
five more batches of vanilla and then I
can get started my chocolate
so now all I gotta do are my chocolate
batches the process is pretty much the
same thing the only difference is I'm
adding cocoa powder to this batch
I don't know if it's because I have
experience just making this dough but
this is becoming really easy to do okay
adding in my vanilla to my milk
I think that was the fastest dough I've
made yet it's looking good guys looking
great growing up in Vietnam there wasn't
any Pocky but there was something
similar it's just like shortbread cookie
sticks and then on the side there would
be like sugar dips or like chocolate
dips I didn't have a proper Pocky stick
until I came over to America and that
was life-changing all right this is
going in the fridge I have one more to
go and I can move on
apparently Pocky was first sold in 1966.
that's actually not that long ago and
they are technically over 50 Pocky
flavors here is my chilled batch of
vanilla this is my chilled batch of
chocolate so after one hour in the
fridge it's definitely really firm so
I'm Gonna Roll this out about 30 to 31
inches long and then about two inches
wide I start in the middle right here
and just kind of use my fingers to
spread out the dough I just hope that
this dough doesn't spread too much when
it's baking because I really need it to
keep its shape
[Music]
so this looks like a big baguette but
it's not it's a giant log of cookie I'm
really scared it's not going to hold its
shape what I'm going to do is I'm going
to wrap it and keep it wrapped while
it's baking so it can keep its shape And
for those of you at home that are
worried that the plastic will melt since
this is such a big batch of cookie while
it's baking it's going to create a lot
of steam and the steam is going to keep
the plastic from melting also like make
sure that the ends are tight it's like a
big compound butter really happy about
this I'm gonna wrap it in
aluminum I have seven more to go and
once all of this is rolled out I'm gonna
put it into the oven at 300 for 90
minutes
while the giant Pocky sticks are baking
I'm gonna work on my toppings I have
dried strawberries here and Oreos that
I'm gonna crush up to make these two
flavors because Jasmine wants all of
them I'm gonna do strawberries first and
these are freeze-dried strawberries run
it through a food processor
then I'm gonna run it through a sieve so
there are no chunks in here oh that
looks so good these will be for the
Pocky sticks and this will be for my
snack later and now I'm going to add in
my Oreos for the cookies and cream
super happy with this it's actually kind
of sticking together because of the
cream
I'm nervous
I'm about to work with an insane amount
of chocolate so it's gonna be tough
guys I was not kidding when I said
there's going to be a lot of chocolate
because this is a whole lot of chocolate
I have Ruby chocolate semi-sweet
chocolate and white chocolate and the
white chocolate is for the cookies and
cream and matcha flavor I have to melt
all of it and I'm going to start with
these semi-sweet chocolate
sorry that was really loud I'm trying
not to make my water boil because if my
water starts to boil it will ruin the
chocolate so I'm trying to keep it at a
simmer working with a big giant spatula
is very tiring because I can't even hold
it like a spatula I'm holding it like
it's just a big stick so this is
actually a cheater way of tempering
chocolate adding coconut oil because
this is a really big batch of chocolate
that I don't want to mess up and waste
so tempering is basically getting
chocolate to a right melted temperature
which is really tricky because it can
bloom and it can start to seize up and
you can't use that chocolate anymore if
your temperature is too low the
chocolate will melt very slow and it
will be a pain in the butt the
chocolate's looking really good nice and
silky I hope Jasmine is going to be
happy because we're going all out with
all of the chocolate flavors for her
birthday
I have my white chocolate here and the
first flavor I'm gonna do is matcha
together I love the smell of matcha it's
turning out to look like the actual
color of the matcha Pocky stick and I'm
really happy about it
that's matcha next up I have my Oreo
crumbles here and I've flavored this
chocolate and that's for the cookies and
cream Pocky just going to add like two
pinches of this crumble in here going
for that like speckled look I want it to
be kind of like a peekaboo not like hey
I'm here you know I gotta work fast here
because I don't want this chocolate to
harden and ruin all my hard work
hi my name is toy and welcome to my
chocolate shop
this is a lot of chocolate so we have
our semi-sweet chocolate here Ruby
chocolate our cookies and cream and our
matcha and the only thing missing are my
giant Pocky sticks so check this out
[Music]
they held up I'm so happy about that
okay these are really really big I'm
just really happy that they held up and
they kept the shape because that was
like the one thing that I was really
worried about these kind of look like
baguettes but no they are big giant
cookies I just don't want it to be
ruined so I have made an executive
decision to pour it over instead of
dipping it in because I feel like
they're just too fragile to be dipped oh
she feels thick but she feels pourable
so here we go
[Music]
oh
I love this green color Okay visually
this looks so good next I'm gonna do the
cookies and cream and it's going right
on top of the chocolate shortbread they
look so good but they have these little
bubbles in there so I'm gonna gently tap
this
all right so let's do a comparison right
now this is the matcha twins
and then this is the cookies and cream
so I'm looking at the Oreo right now and
it looks like there's more of these
speckled in there I'm going to add some
of this crumbled Oreos onto the cookies
and cream
good job you're doing great
now I have the strawberry and the
chocolate left to do the clock is still
ticking so I can't mess up here Gotta
Move quick just gonna lightly tap to
remove
little bubbles
I'm looking at the strawberry right now
and it has little specks of strawberry
in there so I am going to use this
strawberry dust from earlier I'm just
going to dust it right over the top of
the strawberry and here are my version
of the giant Pocky sticks I have cookies
and cream matcha chocolate and
strawberry these four turned out great I
gotta make four more and let them rest
for an hour and then I can party with
Jasmine
and here it is my version of giant Pocky
sticks all boxed up and I'm ready to
party Jasmine come on out please oh my
God thank you thank you this is the best
birthday happy birthday
oh my God it's a party of two exactly
matcha chocolate strawberry and cookies
and cream this literally looks like the
exact replica of Pocky when I was a kid
this is exactly what I hope to be eating
so do you want to dig in yes and how
should we eat this my inner child wants
to just take it out and take a big bite
okay let's do it okay cheers
[Music]
like this is making me feel
are you ready oh my God
[Music]
wow they're like baguettes
but big cookie but big cookie
[Music]
the matcha is really good now you try
this one okay here
these are so luxurious they're really
like elevated Pockets wait this has been
such an amazing birthday gift thank you
so much of course thank you so much for
the challenge I can now say that I have
made my own version of big old giant
Pocky sticks thanks for watching in the
comments let me know what I should make
big next and I'll see you next time
peace peace
[Music]